hey guys its benefits veggie from GE
tracker and in this video I'm going to
talk about I'm going to go back to how
to spot many short-term bubbles now this
was requested by one of you guys you
guys wanted me to talk more about how to
look at a graph and determine whether or
not an items in a skyrocket or crash now
with this video though it's not going to
so much about looking at the graph per
se and making these predictions rather
the importance of game knowledge because
the more you know about the game the
more of an informed merchant you are and
the more smart investments you can make
to prepare yourself for any volatile
price changes now this was an item that
I was actually collecting and I wasn't
intending on flipping this whatsoever
and by a stroke of luck it had
skyrocketed from 30 gp2 over 200 and I
felt really bad trying to sell this back
at the grand exchange because it was
actually a friend of mine in the disk or
chat who was very generous enough to
start donating some of these items to me
you know which I never asked for which
I'm really appreciative to and when this
happened I approached him and I you know
I talked him over with this and he said
that it's fine you know you can you can
sell you can sell the item back with the
intention that I was going to recollect
the same item with all the money that I
may offer this which i made about with
the money with the item that I had on my
main account i made like 10 and 12
million off of this flip or wasn't
really a flip it was a stroke of luck
but honor my other accounts i made a lot
more but that's i won't go into that um
so if we look at the graph here
if we click on the yearly graph we're
going to see that this item has you know
has its bumps here and there and it
skyrocketed once before okay it's hit
200 once before but one thing you should
notice what this yearly graph is that
it's taking the average of all the
prices within that time frame so for the
item they had 200 and show it here you
know that's pretty significant because
in a more recent time it shows that as
140 over here but if we look at a
shorter time frame we can we can see
that it was really you know hitting
above 200 so if we look at this if we
look at the shorter time frame we're
going to notice right here that there's
this huge bike and buy offers and the
sell offers you know slowly caught up to
them but it was first the buy offers
that first push this up so wasn't it
wasn't merchants that were pushing this
it wasn't any kind of manipulation on
their end but rather I tried looking
around any updates and game that may
have caused this item to skyrocket I
couldn't find anything well actually let
me show you guys what I was talking
about it's a bucket of milk okay and
normally a bucket of milk is usually
like from 20 to 30 GP so you can imagine
how I was surprised that this was
selling for like 230 GP because I went
on to my account all of a sudden it was
saying that I was 10 million richer when
I hadn't done anything for that to
happen
so so we know that this was this was
caused by the buyers and this wasn't a
manipulation of merchant and we can see
that down here that there was a whole
bunch of buy offers like there was a
huge demand for some reason and there
wasn't really that many sell offers you
know there wasn't really that many
people that had buckets and milk stored
I was probably one of the few that did
so out of the blue there was this huge
demand which again basic economics says
said that the morn item that is in
demand as opposed to their supply for it
that items going to skyrocket which
clearly happened here but so how do we
how do we know the Cylons going to crash
how do we know that this isn't going to
be a permanent change in game well like
I said in the beginning of this video
this all goes back to gain knowledge so
I went on RS wiki and I looked up bucket
of milk okay and I already knew this
stuff beforehand but this is this is an
example for you guys so if you guys
wanted to find out why an item might be
rising or it maybe it'll crash and you
want to you want to predict that you're
going to want to investigate what this
item is used for how it can be obtained
etc etc so by looking at this I notice
that there's really nothing significant
at all that would make this item useful
sure it might have been used for a mini
quests I mean you could use it to feed
your cat but really there was nothing
there's nearly nothing purposeful but if
like if I look down here obtaining
buckets of milk okay so how do i how do
i obtain a bucket of milk why would this
item suddenly go from 20 GP to 200 gb
and for every class if first glance it
says that I can you know milk a cow
dairy cows yet attained buckets and milk
which I've tried and it takes forever I
would not suggest it to anybody
and then there's another you can it
spawned in a hut in relic ax or you
could actually buy it for 12 coins at
the grand tree or you can buy it from
the from this chest I don't I don't know
I'm not gonna pronounce that but it's
from the recipe for disaster request and
if I click on this it's showing me that
at a base margin that there's about 50
of these and a stock any given point I'm
and they're selling for 12 GP each and
it's saying I can sell it back for the
GE 55 gph now before anyone gets upset
like saying all you ruined a money maker
this is a horrible this is a horrible
money maker ok because I've already
tested this out you have to think about
it none of these items are in huge
demand if you try buying like 50,000
buckets of milk by doing this method and
you try going to the G and selling them
well you just you just increase a
massive supply when there's really no
one to buy this item so you're just
gonna use it's going to crash so
basically I call those self and Ruffing
methods itself nerfing this isn't this
isn't a money maker by any means so you
guys shouldn't get your panties in a
bunch because of that but besides the
point this item you can buy for 12 GP
each and even lower when I when I went
in Game two check again I could even buy
it the first bucket about 47 GP ok so
right off the bat this item can be
obtained for much lower than what this
graph is showing me down here at 200 GP
so instantly I should think this item
has been completely artificially
inflated and there's no way that this
could stay at such a high cost
indefinitely it's impossible it's just
not going to happen so
when I had what I did was I ended up
taking advantages and I ended up selling
my stock I'm part of this I'm part of
the sellers here actually sold a huge
portion of my buckets of milk but at the
very end when I started yet um nearing
the end of my stock I purposefully
crashed the price to tell it add 20g p
beach now that might upset some of you
guys but I did that to purposely stable
this item once again you know I'm trying
to forcefully push the community to
realize this item is not worth 200 g ph
and people were being affected by this
you know merchants were flipping this
for 50 gph and buying huge quantities of
it any given point in time now as to why
this item might have skyrocketed i went
into the discord chat to ask some of the
guys you know what would point out with
us because i don't know everything and
obviously there was no updates and game
that made this bucket of milk useful and
as it turns out there was a streamer a
twitch streamer who said that he was
going to start collecting these once a
week and he's a PI his popular streamer
so eventually all his fans started you
know buying huge quantities of buckets
and milk so they could donate to him but
that's that's real clipped even though a
screamer says he's going to start
collecting these that that influx of
price can't remain high indefinitely and
we're going to go back to this because
you know you can buy it for so cheap it
there's no reason why this item should
be at a price of 200 g ph and then if we
look at a closer time frame we can
notice that it's now stabilized and it's
now back to 54 tgp and there's not that
huge margin of like 50 GP that was
having earlier earlier during last month
when this huge pike happened
so yeah that's how to spot no potential
potential crashes before they happen and
that's the importance of game at all
that you know when you guys are looking
at these charts you should try and if
you find any obscurities like this you
find any bumps you know try and go on RS
wiki try and do some research on this
item CY might of this item and
skyrocketed and why it crashed ok if it
has skyrocketed maybe there was some
reason like the twitch streamer like I
had mentioned earlier who said he was
gonna start collecting these but knowing
fully well that I can get this at a much
lower cost that it's gonna crash very
soon and it did then take very long for
that to crash took maybe like about a
week so yeah that's how to crop how to
spot potential crashed but really happen
and if you guys have any other
suggestions about what type of videos
you guys want to see you know this was a
suggestion made by one of you guys so if
you guys have been suggested i will make
a video about it so thank you so much
guys for your support so far make sure
to leave a comment down below on your
thoughts maybe suggestions do you guys
want to see in future videos leave a
like if you like this video and
subscribe to see any future content and
good luck machine guys until next time
you
[Music]